il monte en a chanté hier soir à
jérusalem le chant des partisans avec
des milliers d'israël il soutenait ainsi
le combat des réfugiés nique
ces juifs soviétiques qui n'ont pas le
droit d'émigrer de quitter l'union
soviétique il montant est arrivé en
début de semaine en israël où il est
reçu comme un chef d'état
charles enderlin des milliers
d'israéliens étaient venus applaudir
anatolie sharansky l'ex refuse nick
reilly remontant à cette manifestation
de solidarité avec le judaïsme
soviétique sous les murailles de la
vieille ville de jérusalem
shalom je voudrais vous dire combien je
suis heureux d'être ici aujourd'hui en
estonie israël va shannara barras mais
les rouches highline en hébreu montant a
dit le traditionnel l'an prochain à
jérusalem
prononcer
o est parti ce moment
briller plus
ce soir pour les quarts
le son
moi je suis venu ici à l'invitation de
deux premiers ministres shimon peres qui
nous avait invité six mois les moyens
déjà un an pour passer dix jours de
vacances
c'est très bien alors un concours de
circonstances a fait que également il ya
eu cette action menée à juste titre pour
la défense des juifs d'urss a immigré et
je devais pas venir en israël j'ai déjà
fait mais je trouve très bien être c'est
dans sa nature ici en israël précisément
j'étais la raison pour laquelle c'est si
et surtout avoir la possibilité de
rencontrer james key qui est l'exemple
même si vous voulez ou avec d'autres
nous nous sommes battus pour la
libération de tir en ski et d'autres de
ses camarades qui continue à être en
prison oui au goulag uniquement parce
qu'ils ont demandé la permission de
droit à l'immigration
on ne doit pas accepter ce genre de
choses même si on peut condamner
ailleurs des choses qui sont aussi
inacceptable ou bien entendu